[Music]
[Music]
so this is the one hundred and fiftieth
anniversary celebration interview with
Professor Isadora singer and let me
start by asking where you were born
where did you grow up I was born in
Detroit Michigan
I don't start over again okay where was
I born I was born in Detroit Michigan in
1924 and I grew up there my parents came
from Poland
I am Agreda to Toronto Canada where they
met and married and then they came to
Detroit in 1923 and what what did your
parents do were they did they also work
my father was a printer and my mother is
seamstress when they arrived my father
tells the story that the printing uni
printers Union was on strike and they
asked him not to break the strike and
gave him five dollars a day not to do
that and he agreed he wrote his mother
back in Poland that it is in fact true
that the streets of the United States
were paved with gold we were very poor
during the Depression as a vivid memory
for me and so I'm particularly concerned
about people who are out of jobs now
because my father was out of a job for a
year or so and we suffered badly at that
time we were there any particular events
or influences in your childhood that you
think helped you to choose that career
path you chose
no I you know I was an all a student all
the time mostly I found school boring I
preferred playing baseball and stuff
like that that was more interested in
athletics then I wasn't anything going
on at school I read a great deal things
did come to an end about my junior year
in high school I had a very good English
teacher and I had a very good chemistry
teacher so the periodic table struck me
as something very exciting and the
English teacher got me to read lots of
good books dust EF ski warrant peace my
oldest daughters named Natasha after
Natasha in war and peace
so those two things had a big impact on
me and woke me up to the excitement of
science I became president of the
science club very quickly and gave
lectures on relativity already as a
senior in high school how did you decide
on the University of Michigan they had a
competition and I either came first or
second in this competition and therefore
I won a scholarship to the University of
Michigan what that meant was I had to
ition paid tuition was $50 a semester as
I say we were very poor and I had
originally gonna go was originally going
to go to Wayne University and live at
home but my mother said you can't you
can't give up fifty dollars twice a year
so I went to Michigan as her his own I
lived in a coop the coop I lived in you
paid two dollars and twenty five cents a
week for room and board
and that I remember the vivid discussion
about getting up to two dollars and
fifty cents a week which we did you must
it must be staggering to look at tuition
prices now absolutely
it's shocking actually but of course
there are a lot of amenities that one
doesn't take into account we didn't have
any at all in fact I survived by having
three jobs at any one time and also by
selling my football tickets which I
could sell illegally for $5.00 a ticket
that lasted two weeks for I so those any
rate the war started when I was a
freshman and I enlisted in the Signal
Corps because they said they would allow
me to continue school until I finished
as long as I took courses in electrical
engineering which I did because I would
they wanted me to become a radar officer
when I finally got it in the army um I
might add that I rushed through school
because I didn't really believe that
they would let me go the full four years
and I got my degree in two and a half
years that must have been difficult
well I might have gotten used to being
at MIT with everything going on so many
things to do
so what is it that drew you to physics
do you think because of my lectures on
relativity in high school I felt that I
didn't really understand the question
what the issue was even though I spoke
about it and so I wanted to learn more
about relativity and I'd heard about
quantum mechanics and so I wanted to
learn that as well actually when I got
to Michigan I did hadn't decided whether
major in physics or in English
literature and what happened was that I
found Stuart students in the poetry
class understood poetry many of them
instinctively easily and I struggled
with it but when I took physics I was
the one who understood what was going on
very quickly and that decided me as to
what path I should take that's a good
way to make the decision that's what I
think first couple of years at the
university is all about and then how did
the interest shift from physics to math
that's kind of complicated
as I say I finished early went into the
army once in the army for two and a half
years but after a year and a half what I
was destined for was greater officer in
the European sector and that was about
ended and we were all moved to go to the
Pacific I was still concerned that as an
undergraduate I didn't understand
relativity or quantum mechanics and I
had heard about extension courses so at
the University of Chicago so on my way
everybody was called redeployment at
that time all of us moving from the east
coast to the west I stopped in Chicago
and went up to the fourth floor of the
building and there was forgotten the
same and a god I think any rate he told
me he did have extension courses in
geometry and then group theory which was
needed for quantum mechanics and so I
enrolled in them and I took them with me
I ended up in the Philippines and ended
up running a a communication school for
the Filipino army when I was out there
and I would get these letters from
corrected papers of mine I studied all
the time my friends played poker and I
did my homework but to answer your
question how did I get in the math what
happened was since all the textbooks for
these correspondence courses were from
the University of Chicago I thought that
would be the place to go and I was
indeed accept it when I said in the math
department because I thought I wanted
more math to understand the physics of
quantum mechanics and relativity which
was in fact the right instinct
but that first year in math was so
wonderful and so beautiful
whereas listening in on the corner
mechanics course it was still the same
rough course i would say then i felt
mathematics was really my my field and i
was right because it was a mathematical
instinct that told me the way they were
teaching one our mechanics was not right
that is in fact true as far as I could
say you decided to stay at the
University of Chicago for your doctorate
yes why well that first year was so
wonderful and remember I didn't have the
right background in math but a lot of
friends supported me and taught me the
material I didn't know i rapidly caught
out and the faculty it was just terrific
there brought new people in on dr a one
of the world's great mathematicians turn
SS cheran came the last year who
influenced me greatly in differential
geometry and we became very good friends
over a long period of time so that was
the place to be so would you consider
him a mentor my two mentors were churned
certainly and Irving Siegel who was my
thesis advisor and who eventually came
to MIT I learned a great deal from both
of them um I wonder if you talk a little
bit more about curving sink Siegel about
everything so you go there well
he was a wonderful and lousy teacher at
the same time we were excited about what
he was doing because he was lecturing on
the forefront of analysis and functional
analysis but he got stuck about halfway
through every lecture and he spent the
rest of the lecture trying to straighten
it out so yeah that makes him a lousy
teacher he didn't get very far in any
one day but I go home and would try and
solve the problem he was stuck with and
I'd either have my solution or I didn't
know how to do it so I was very eager to
see what he was going to do at the
lesson next meeting in the class and I
could compare my solution with his if I
had one or I could see where he did
something that I hadn't understood and
so it was essentially doing research
every time on your own so that's one way
in which he was a very exciting teacher
also he stayed late at night and most of
us as students stayed late at night his
door was always open so late at night I
could go in and it wasn't a matter of
talking about my dissertation we did
that was for about five minutes but we'd
spend the rest of the time talking about
mathematics and the importance of
functional analysis so that's how he
influenced me a great deal and gave me a
very good background in analysis Chern
came the last year I was there and he'd
feel this differential geometry and I
only listened to his course and took
notes but I immediately felt that I was
in the wrong field I was so taken by his
geometric view and they the instruments
he used in order to reflect that
geometric view and it was too late for
to me for me to make any changes but
you'll see that it had a great impact on
me and on MIT when we get to it so how
did you come to MIT well then I got my
degree I had two offers one to the
Institute for Advanced Study
to be with matter with me I got an MIT I
had an offer and that offer was $50 more
than the one from the Institute for
Advanced Study so naturally I took it I
had a family already and that was the
thing to do do you remember what your
first impressions were of MIT I'm so
glad you asked me about my first
impression so you said you liked stories
and I'm going to tell you when I've
often spoke about in fact I'm gonna
reminisce because I'm retiring June 30th
and I arrived at MIT July 1st 1950 so
that's 60 years with some time away but
July 1st will celebrate the 60s
60 years and I'm about to tell you the
first day so I came over cross I was
staying in Back Bay across the river and
went to a building to to meet Ted Martin
who is a chairman and he had won
secretary Ruth Goodwin went into the
office there was a guy reading the globe
and I'm told Ruth who I was he put down
his paper and said I'm Ambrose Singer we
got a seminar going in late groups come
on let's go I said but I have to see
professor Barton he said Oh that'll keep
come on
so I went to the seminar and I met a
number of people who got to be good
friends some mathematicians of note
George Whitehead particularly in
topology and then we went back and I did
talk to
a chair and Ambrose waited for me and
then he said we meet for coffee at 11
p.m. I'll pick you up where do you stay
so he did pick me up that night around
11:00 we went to this terrible coffee
shop haze Bickford in the middle of
nowhere and Boston and there I met the
same group who were in the seminar and
Kate Whitehead George while his wife was
there and also mathematician and we
talked for a bit
and then I thought Ambrose was going to
take me home
he did not he simply showed me what
Boston was about drove around for a long
time and dropped me off about 3:00 in
the morning and I went up to this
apartment that I had been given for a
few days and I you know you have to
remember that I hadn't been home because
I'd left for the university I then spent
three years in the Army
and I then spent three and a half years
at university chicago so I really had no
home I went up to my bedroom and said
I'm home this is my home and that's my
first day at MIT
do you remember so you had had
experience at two other universities was
there anything that struck you as
different when you got on the campus and
kind of got to know the students and the
faculty and the culture here not
immediately but as time went on I saw a
considerable difference between the two
places one of the important things that
Chicago was it was a graduate school for
us undergraduate teaching was done by
another division of the University as a
graduate student we saw very little of
undergraduates brilliant as they were I
would mostly see him in a locker room or
in some sport or another and had very
little contact with him did no teaching
there MIT was entirely different I was a
an important and enormous load our
responsibility of teaching
undergraduates and that was that has
been done with greater poem as far as
I'm concerned so MIT was a place where
he did research but teaching was
extremely important
was was that so it was there anything
about it that was a surprise when you
sort of got to know undergraduates
wasn't her a surprise at MIT either in
their attitude or what you found you got
from the relationship or anything like
that well it took a while for me to
think of those terms I'm going to say
what happened was that Ambrose asked me
what Sharon had done in his course and
he wanted me to discuss it and explain
it to everybody he was a stickler for
details so I ended up more or less
lecturing on differential geometry to
him learning it with him and
reorganizing it into a more modern
language than Chern used we gave courses
in it and students wrote books about it
and so MIT became a center for a
differential geometry on the basis of
what we tried to do with really the
notes of my course from Chicago now
asked of the difference the feeling that
I had was that I could there was a kind
of freedom I could give a course
immediately on new material to
undergraduates and recently in fact
because I was looking for some old notes
I was really shocked and how much large
undergraduate teaching I did at the time
with the freedom of reorganizing the
course I gave a course in is called
algebra matrix theory and I just changed
it completely into a modern form and I
still have former students who are now
well-known mathematicians who remind me
whenever we meet
I had given this remarkable course with
a huge audience to 190 the big room
I gave lectures in there frequently and
I was allowed to do that criticized of
course by some old-timers but there was
a freedom to change courses so us to
adapt to modern times you must I must
tell you that the 50s was a period of
great development in mathematics and so
between seminars reorganizing courses
and keeping up with what was happening
topology geometry a lot of things were
happening at that time we had many
seminars week we could immediately put
them in the course work and we were
allowed to freedom to do that that I had
not known before but only because I
wasn't you know I couldn't do that at
Chicago because I was a student whereas
here I wasn't the student anymore and
that was really except those were
exciting times is there a particular
reason the 50s was such a busy time for
mathematics yeah because the war end and
just the influx of people there were a
number of very good French
mathematicians who were prisoners of war
or conscientious objectors that now and
they were one of the leaders in this
development so we got a lot of new stuff
coming out of out of France and then it
was German and what he was doing and
what he had done and the implications of
it so a lot of things were happening
that were brand-new
the 50s were very special
so can we sort of walk through the
various areas of interest that you've
had over the years starting with
differential geometry we'd talk about
the work you've done in that and maybe
why it's particularly interesting to you
why it's captured your attention
I think what I really like in
mathematics is the connections between
different fields and geometry captured
my attention because it combined
topology with geometric insight and you
needed analysis which I learned from
Irving single in order to well what we
call hard to get existence theorem in
order to solve certain equations which
came up from geometry you needed some
strength and analysis in order to solve
those equations and I like that
combination of all three things and
that's what attracted me to geometry and
in fact again what we did at MIT was all
of courses that needed these backgrounds
in other fields Ambrose and I revised he
and we revised the geometry course as
well to be modern and I think among them
all a geometry course is pretty much
what it was when we revised them by then
the sixth season I assume they had not
been revised for a while before that
that's right they were pretty
old-fashioned than that this is an
opportunity of Young Turks coming and
doing some other things it was your
impression that the mathematics
department was a little behind the times
when you arrived I don't know the only
department I had been acquainted with
Chicago and it certainly was not behind
the times
I guess because I guess maybe MIT was a
little and we were the first Ambrose was
the leader I must say it was his energy
that said we should do this that the
other thing and I provided some of
energy to help him along and so it did
need some modernization in the 50s so we
had terrific people people like George
Whitehead and Norbert Weiner was still
there but he was doing his own thing and
his main contributions to mathematics
were already finished by then well
that's probably why they hired you but
that's probably why they hired you they
bring some of the University of Chicago
newer stuff to MIT well it took a while
you know I'm always kid to the
department when I had a program of
instructors more instructors and I was a
more instructor there from 50 to 52 but
they did not keep me on it was only
supposed to be a two-year appointment
and most of us left and I went to UCLA
but I say they'd sent me to the minor
leagues for for training and they did
and it was good for me actually and I
came back four years later and that's
really when I started revising the
department and I think Ambrose and
Whitehead over here were very eager to
have me come back and that's why the
department decided to have me come back
what about the area of partial
differential equations that's part of
what I call analysis and those equations
are what come up in differential
geometry many times and it's solving
those equations that are critical for
many problems in geometry and I have
mathematical physics
yes that came later mathematical physics
my interests in mathematical physics
started with something called self-dual
solutions some to partial differential
equations and those self-dual equations
were much simpler than the usual ones
you find in what's called gates theory
and I was struck by the physicists
Polyakov and company coming up with
these geometric solutions to equations
and we mathematicians had not seen them
and I thought that it was blind spot on
our part not to have understood that
these equations could be simplified this
way and then I got interested in saying
well why do they want these what's
happening and this has to do with what's
called gauge theory in physics which
turns out to be something in mathematics
fiber bundles that we knew in geometry
so I was struck by what they had done
struck about this dictionary called the
Wuyang dictionary that related
mathematical terms in geometry to
physics terms in gates theory and so I
wanted to know where all this was
leading to and I started a seminar and
they of course the connections between
math and physics now I did not do that
here in 77 I decided for personal
reasons to go to the west coast and I
went to Berkeley and I spent seven years
at Berkeley MIT was not happy about that
and what they did has asked me to retire
and make sure that I could return easily
and come out of retirement so I started
the seminar in Berkeley and every year I
got a call from him it2 asked me come
back
and I got very impatient with Berkeley
and they made the critical call I said
yes I'm coming up I'm coming home and I
did what was different about the the
atmosphere of culture at Berkeley that
didn't fit as well as the MIT one as I
said I went there for personal reasons
not for scientific reasons but there I
did witness a change in culture it's as
if the younger people felt that there
were some connections between math and
physics that hadn't been explored and
they were excited about my running a
course in giving a seminar and three of
our best students as students that I had
at Berkeley who got involved in this
connection between geometry math and
mathematics and gates theory and physics
wrote their thesis about these matters
and all three of them are very close
friends why now
so why did you ultimately decide to come
back Berkeley politically I didn't care
for mixture in the university although
it had some brilliant people by and
large there were people who are still
involved and I don't know the
revolutionary times political issues and
they had more to say at the University
than the really brilliant people who
were there and ultimately I got
impatient with all that politics
interfering with real science and I was
at one of those days what's she won't
think that MIT called me and again and
asked me to come back I did is this a
good time to talk about your theorem and
how that came about
yes but I'd like to have one more we're
talking about stories my wife and two
daughters we're very unhappy about
moving east when they always said they
wanted to go back especially my children
two daughters
well it now happens that daughter emily
has biotech editor of technology reviews
here and my other daughter Annabelle
received her PhD in brain and cognitive
sciences at the University of California
San Francisco and elected to be a
postdoc here at MIT so now they're both
here and I see them frequently
so you knew best after all I wouldn't
know but it's worked out
so how how did your collaboration and
your theorem develop can you tell me
that story yes I knew I got to know
Michel Lotito when I was at the
Institute for Advanced Study in 1955
that was a very good year we had a lot
of top mathematicians there and I got to
know Michel well and there was a change
in my family circumstances and I was on
sabbatical and I needed to go to
someplace where English was spoken and
so I called Michael he himself had just
arrived at Oxford and I asked whether
there was a place for me he simply said
come we'll arrange so my wife and I and
son moved to Oxford and after I got
settled and first day I was worrying
myself by one of those flyers and he
came up and he asked me a question which
was a question in his field my was the
Hebert of genus and integer for spend
manifolds that was the question and I
looked at him and I said Michael why are
you asking me that question you know the
answer to that really probing him that
he had some other reason for asking
he said well yes I do know the answer
but I feel there's a deeper reason for
it I like that answer
and although I was working on another
problem I spent the spring in the
gardens of Oxford colleges sitting on
benches thinking about that problem and
finally I thought I knew the answer to
it and then it involved
the dirac operator Dirac's equation for
a spinning electron which I knew for
other reasons and involved differential
equations and analysis and some geometry
so the next day I came to Michael's
office and said look Michael I think
you're getting an immature peak it's a
number of solutions to this equation
moreover if we do a little bit of
juggling you'll see that all the
equations that give you hit at doose's
answers can all be described in terms of
this these geometric operators you're
just counting the number of answered
solutions and that's why you're getting
integers no it just took overnight for
Michael to say yeah we can write down a
formula for olap and that started our
collaboration on the index there and
actually nine months from the time he
asked me the question at that time we
had a complete proof of the index error
I had a new baby what a baby and crew in
a really something very robust
development so as as someone you know
without a science background is there a
way you can explain the theorem in kind
of lay terms and I understand if that's
not possible
well it's difficult to do
I can just give you a motivation
forehead to some extent you're trying to
solve an equation and you want to find
the solution something called the
phantom alternative where you look at
the number of solutions and you also
look at the number of different ways you
cannot get a solution and you compare
the difference of the two what you'd
really like is to have that equal to
zero and that difference is called the
index index of this equation you'd like
it to be the zero because and it would
say that existence implies uniqueness
and uniqueness implies existence
existence is well any rate those are the
two integers if they're equal then you
know as I said existence implies
uniqueness uniqueness implies existence
well it's much easier to show uniqueness
than there is existence so if you know
it's zero you only have to solve half
the problem and you only solve the
easier half the problem and that was the
original motivation for defining the
saying what you meant by the index and
the reason our theorem was so exciting
aside from the fact that it combined a
lot of different fields is it gave you
an answer in geometric terms the number
of solutions were the number of holes in
this particular object you see so it put
geometry into this partial differential
equation answer and that's what made it
exciting can you explain how how how
that led to this sort of breakdown
between
yields between physics and math for
example well there are two questions I
think when you say the breakdown between
one is in mathematics itself this had
such impact because we were using
geometry topology little algebraic
geometry and analysis all together to
get a very striking solution so that
broke down barriers between fields a
great deal and that because it was so
striking those barriers have stayed down
all this time except for people who were
very fixed in a given subject physics is
another matter because string theory
came along and it turns out they needed
some aspects of mathematics in order to
solve their problem what's called K
theory and ultimately they needed the
index theorem and K theory to be able to
answer some questions and string theory
and so it turns out very quickly
physicists move rapidly and absorb
mathematics very rapidly so they became
experts in K theory and the index there
very quickly and I asked penetrating
questions about the subject again very
quickly it's interesting that at E and I
wrote our last paper in 84 and it was on
the applications of the index theorem to
string theory anomalies it's called a
cancellation of anomalies and physics
and we had a geometric way or
mathematical way of explaining how those
how nominees came about and how to
eliminate them and that's what
physicists wanted
do you think it was you know was it your
particular exposure and background in
geometry starting at the University of
Chicago that helped you to see this in a
different way do you know what it was
that allowed you to figure this out
without when no one else had done it up
to that point well I would say what
allowed me to make progress on all these
things was as I said originally I loved
the interconnections between fields I
found that most exciting so I was well
trained at Chicago between the analysis
and see how much way that I had learned
there and we had a very good policy
group headed by George Whitehead and I
learned a lot of topology then so it was
those connections that allowed me to put
them together when needed I mean it just
happened you're sitting at a park bench
the old story and suddenly it clicked
yeah it's a great image to you know
because as you pass people in a park and
you see them on a park bench you don't
figure that they're necessarily thinking
about science changing theorems but well
I was noted for Lange and sitting on a
park bench with pencil and a pad of
paper all the time
do you as you look forward are there do
you have expectations for for other
things that you think this will help to
explain or unlock in the future or could
it be anything well it turns out
that index theory is used in a number of
different ways and in physics I
hesitated because his subject called
noncommutative geometry which is too
complicated to explain here but I feel
index serious influence has influenced
that and I want to use some aspects of
non-euclidean geometry in the future to
explain some things that are going on
with black holes so I'm still interested
in physics get problems in physics but I
want to use more sophisticated methods
than I then are presently available I in
physics to attack those problems one of
the reasons I am retiring is so I can
focus on that book material without any
obligations by by sort of uniting
physics and mathematics in a way that
they hadn't been before what kinds of
issues have people subsequently been
able to deal with that they couldn't
have dealt with without that that closer
connection
well for example index theory is used to
explain entropy in black holes it
computes certain kinds of black holes
and their entropy you have to use the
number of solutions to a differential
equation for the entropy so there's an
application that was kind of unexpected
Steve Hawking talked about entropy in
the recent video TV I think I'm
hesitating because I'm just gonna repeat
myself I think there parts of
mathematics like noncommutative geometry
they have had some impact on physics but
I think it'll have more so on black
holes and that's a so one of many
subjects I want to look into in the near
future there's some aspects of topology
it's gotten very sophisticated again
partly because of index theory that
tries to combine string theory with a
rather axiomatic topology I would call
it and I think that's gonna have some
impact on physics as well these are
coming subjects that I'm just guessing
about really
but back when you came up with the index
theorem you didn't really know at that
point all of the ramifications that it
would know that's theorem as you know
forty years of it has always been robust
even now we're working on my colleagues
and I am going to go back to talk about
working on some aspects of a rather
sophisticated index theorem that
nobody's played with before that must be
quite an accomplishment to feel that
you've you have sort of a long term
contribution that keeps kind of giving
birth I'm very lucky I read that you've
made some comments about the frustration
of communicating with younger
mathematicians about jargon and I wonder
if you could explain that every field
has its terminology not just in
mathematics but whatever you're not
really in the feel until you understand
that jargon in mathematics that jargon
plays an important role particularly for
young people to feel are part of the
field whereas this an old-timer
naturally I don't I'm not good at
learning other languages anyway so I am
unhappy with that jargon and I'm unhappy
when young people try and explain
something in that jargon and so if
anything I just try and eliminate it and
ask now what are you really talking
about can you put it in more
straightforward terms so give me an
example of what you mean and so on
impatient about that and not just with
young people but it's true with many
experts and for example the difference
between a good colloquium lecturer and
the poor one is whether the speaker uses
jargon or not and as someone who works
in communications I completely agree
with you it's the difference between
talking to impress or talking to
communicate yes and there is a
difference absolutely let me ask a
little about some of your other work you
were chair of the committee of science
and public policy at the National
Academy of Science yes I can talk a
little about that that was a very
exciting period for me my period in
Washington and that's part of what I did
we attacked a number of problems one of
the things we did was describe I think
it was the first report on what to do
with nuclear wastes that we had I had
one experience where with the internet
and computers just breaking out I had a
meeting where we discussed the privacy
matters and the threat to privacy by
with what was coming but I was way ahead
of my time nobody on the committee
really went along with that that's going
to happen I mention it because now we're
quite concerned about that privacy
sometimes I don't know 20 odd years
ahead of the game but the important
thing is for me was I met so many
brilliant creative people there and it
was exciting to be with them all the
time and then make me aware of how
creative human beings can be and how
constructive they can be we were very
careful in choosing my secretary and I
and choosing people who might serve and
we had terrific people and to tell you
another story and you know I knew Jerry
Wiesner from first year I was here he
was running the electronic lab at the
time and I came to see him because I had
an idea based on Norbert Wiener of
putting a multiple probe on the optic
nerve and using it as a television set
for people who were blind and he looked
at me then and said well we can only put
one probe in now but if you want to come
and work at my laboratory you have a job
it says how we met and talked but anyway
when he was president of MIT he I went
to see him about something else and he
congratulated me on being a chair and I
was sheepish saying it would take away
from my research and he said no it won't
is the experience and the broadening
that you'll get then when you go back to
mathematics he'll have an entirely
different view about what you want to do
and how you want to do it he was how
slowly right how did it change how did
that be a change by your experience I
simply spent instead of focusing on the
technical aspects of problem I was
working out I just took a step back and
said do I want to do this why do I want
to do this where does it fit in my view
of mathematics and often that that
changed how I went about things
how about your your experience of being
on the White House Science Council that
was very exciting I can't speak much
about that I think much of it is still
confidential but again that was a
learning experience again there were
terrific people on that Paul Gray for
example and we have to talk about the
various presidents of MIT and we haven't
talked about why they might tea per se
but we should we will okay but I had I
didn't we didn't focus on much Reagan's
program as president for the country it
was mostly problems international that
one was concerned with I can't go into
but I will mention one that I came up at
that time that's when one discovered
aids and we had to discuss with the
science advisor how he would approach
the president with this horrendous
problem and President Reagan was very
positive about the whole thing he said
well what we suggested that he got a
committee to look into it in mic
recommendations and he said immediately
you know he had no prejudices of any
sort yes let's do that immediately and
let's see what we come up with and the
first thing they came up with which was
important was to emphasize cleanliness I
was first recommendation in the
committee and I think they did a very
good job that's
you know that's an example of something
that came our way from time to time was
it important to you to just sort of put
in this time in the public sector the
part of the academy was important I
learned a great deal there and being on
the White House Science Council was just
one of those things that I felt well I
feel I'm pretty level-headed guy if I
can be useful to them I don't know why
they want a mathematician but if I can
be useful to them and by all means I
have to do it just as a citizen more
than anything and in fact I remember the
science advisor one morning after a
heavy meeting the night before coming in
and said is your suggestion solves the
problem how can you be so smart you're
just a mathematician so you can see
they're all mathematics and that heady
envira did that did you get any sort of
different perspective from that that
experienced in DC that you brought back
and then somehow contributed to what you
did back at MIT or was it more an issue
of personal growth
huh I got a I don't think it's growth
but I think there is a different
perspective for example as I mentioned I
served then they aren't forces her
almost three years and I had a certain
perspective about the Armed Forces I
like my freedom and in that respect I
hated being incarcerated so sweet but I
came to healthy respect for the Armed
Forces the generals I talked to who came
to various meetings that were necessary
had lunch with the general who
responsibilities would be to push the
button if we were going to use nuclear
weapons and I said to myself then that
their choice was impeccable and so in
general I concluded that their choice of
people and how they go about it is
remarkable much better than the way we
choose people for tenure and stuff like
that they were remarkable and the
generals I'd have lunch with from time
to time often we would have to go to the
cafeteria because there wasn't enough
food around for them you know they liked
the White House Council would have lunch
but nobody else could who is visiting
and I elected to go over to cafeteria
with our visitor self no no they were I
have a lot of respect for the military
on the basis of what I learned at that
time and I got a better feeling for the
chain of command that occurs in the
White House at that time is the is the
is the difference and this is only a
guess on my part it's the difference
that they're they're able to look at and
evaluate more
almost intangible qualities then might
be involved in the decision for tenure
they're looking more at what the person
contributes as an individual I don't
know the answer to that I can only say
that there's so many little things that
made me come to the cannolis for example
the aid to the science advisor Jay
Keyworth had been a nuclear have been in
charge of a nuclear submarine before
that well you can imagine there when we
were to meet there was always one crisis
I mentioned one or two and coming up all
the time I don't think I've ever met a
person as cool as he was there was no
crisis that he couldn't have something
constructive to say about how to handle
it and all in a cool manner and as I
said that was the feeling I had about
the general who would have to push the
bomb it's those individuals and their
personalities have led me to believe
that the selection process must be
awfully good sheila widnall i think will
confirm that because he was Secretary of
the Navy was it and I think she'll
confirm that sense of selection that
they have that's better than ours you
were a Sloan fellow and a Guggenheim
Fellow two times is there anything about
the experience that that opportunity
that you'd want to talk about could you
repeat the question you were a Sloan
fellow yes and a Guggenheim Fellow two
times yes what does that experience add
well the main thing is freedom I think
all research people want the freedom to
do their work and they gave me a great
deal of freedom so that I could just do
what I wanted
and I'm very indebted to those
foundations for allowing me the freedom
to do what I wanted freedom is a theme
it's the fame yes have you been you've
been teaching first semester calculus
all along haven't you
not all along that's very interesting
well since you brought up teaching I had
occasion I was looking for hold notes of
mine on the lecture I gave a long time
ago what I found was a series of courses
that I'd given in large classrooms and
the revision of subjects and including
at the beginning teaching calculus we
all taught calculus that time but for
many years I only taught graduate
courses or that high level undergraduate
courses I don't know what possessed me
but I decided to be a TA in the first
calculus course to freshman I think I
did it because my good friend ran the
whole program one year and I just
I think what motivated me was I was too
far removed from MIT on the
undergraduate level and this gave me a
chance to come back and in fact it was a
wonderful experience the two years that
I did it making contact with freshmen
again they liked my lecturing and in
fact whoever ran the program had
instructors who were come from abroad to
come in and listen to how I handle the
course one of the important things that
happened
Arthur Matic was in charge of the
calculus program
he's a fantastically good lecture
shellman really and he arranged one time
I one time I was doing that that we TAS
would not be responsible for final exams
or making up problems hork rating and
that changed our relationship with the
undergraduates with the freshmen because
we were now their friend not judging
them and I'd often come in and say well
what it so-and-so do this year this this
time this I'd say and I'd say well
that's not the way to go about it I
think you're really to see it you do it
this way so there was that sense of
freedom that I could say what I wanted
and the students understood that I was
there to help them and not to judge
repeating myself and that was an
entirely good relationship moreover I
got to know some of the students quite
well and in every class freshman class
at least to where the students could be
world famous scientists engineers
anything he wanted to do they were the
many of them elected to do other things
so it was very personal experience for
me and I had made friends I saw kids who
seemed to have nothing girl to show a
great deal and that made it such a
exciting different experience and made
me feel part of MIT that I hadn't felt
for many years everybody was surprised
that I did it a couple of times do you
have a philosophy of teaching or you
know have a sort of teaching integrate
with your other work there integrate the
teaching is integrated with my other
work in the sense that I never think of
research in quotation marks all I want
to do is understand what's going on and
the motivation for understanding is when
I understand it then I can explain it to
somebody so there's a link between for
me between doing research doing research
means understanding something that I
don't understand and then maybe it turns
out nobody else understands and when I
do understand that the link is I want to
tell them about it so therefore in the
sense I'm a good teacher I can put
myself in the position of a student huh
I know what they don't understand and
now if I know them well enough I can
kind of explain what they don't
understand in terms that they can
comprehend so it's that empathy that I
have that makes me a good teacher do you
learn from your students
rarely on the graduate level I have
learned a lot for my graduate students
on the undergraduate level know you've
had a number of visiting appointments at
UCLA in Columbia Princeton and you were
at Berkeley when you go off and spend
time at other academic institutions does
that come back in any way in benefit MIT
is there a value from those experiences
well of course all experiences are
valuable every day is valuable but no
I'm I'm impressed with MIT yeah we do
things right not just in the math
department not really impressed with how
constructive everybody is here and I
think we do a better job then anywhere
else that I know so I haven't learned
anything from other schools that we need
to know had the MIT well that's an
important lesson right there yes I think
so um were you surprised to be chosen an
institute professor yes tell me why well
it's just never never occurred to me I
talked to Paul Gray about it recently
and he said one of the joys for him this
as president was to notify people and he
talked about one case where the
professor came in shaking and said
immediately what have I done wrong what
have I done wrong and I confessed to
Paul that when I came to see him that
was what I felt that I had been called
in because I'd done something wrong but
I kept my mouth shut so I was shocked
delighted of course when he told me how
has it changed the nature of your
relationship with MIT if at all it
changed my relationship with the math
department
because it meant I reported directly to
the Provost and then I was freed into
what I wanted and that again that
freedom meant a great deal to me my math
physics seminar was mostly on my mind
and I spent most of my time making sure
that that ran well and more recently we
had a new seminar called new
opportunities for mathematics and other
fields where we got visitors from other
fields to talk about possible
connections with mathematics I did that
for a year and a half and that was very
exciting also again I learned a great
deal from these people when we go out to
dinner and I'd be talking to people who
are experts in an entirely different
field and that was exciting that's what
I'm doing over here it's great fun yes
okay you have a list of some incredibly
prestigious awards and honors and I'm
wondering if any in particular have
meant more than the others or were very
meaningful to you well the a bell prize
was the most prestigious and I think
because of that it means more to me
it's you know they had tea a singer
index there Michael and I won the prize
together the Atia singer in the XM did
have an impact over some 40 years it's
still having an impact and they have
that recognized and sort of recognized
throughout the world not just in the
mathematical world I thought was very
important for mathematics and certainly
important for me in the sense that I
feel I don't know I can't express how I
feel about it let's talk about MIT yes
why have you stayed here so long what is
it about your career
excuse me your career interest your
research interests that have meshed so
well with the environment here
why have I stayed here so long I think
I'll expand on it but the correct answer
is it's the best place to be the issue
is why we talked about freedom and
that's part of it but I think the when
you put it this way you know the
Japanese have a game and they when they
want to evaluate what a person is or the
character the game is to say one word to
do that Forex its energy someone else
it's depth for me the one word for MIT
is generosity it's a generous place for
me it's been the generous place freedom
is part of that generosity it's a place
where I grew up
scientifically remind you of my
background I came as a grad student has
almost three years in the Army I was way
behind I came here and got involved and
what we were doing and gradually as time
went and you know I had to go away and
then I came back gradually as time went
on even before the index theorem it sort
of became clear we went out to lunch did
one thing or another that questions
would come up and after a while I'd say
well maybe we're looking at it wrong
maybe we should look at it this way and
it changed our picture of the issue and
after a time it just there'd be a
discussion and there be silence and
everybody would turn to me
it's in that sense that I kind of grew
up at MIT and then I had the freedom
soon enough to do what I wanted before
the index theorem because I gave I was a
good lecturer and I went do things
differently than others and that was
much appreciated
that generosity shows up in a lot of
ways open course where's my great
example started as a recommendation by
some faculty members and others working
hard on their courses so it would I
their administration finding funds to
have it happen - that's a great
reflection of MIT per se as to what
we're about and I've always found the
administration very eager to allow
faculty and students the freedom to do
something constructive and different and
there was no reason to leave place as
wonderful as that
I maybe we should let let's talk about
the presidents all right
and I'll leave it to you who would you
like to speak about or make a comment
about well I've been fortunate and no
one getting to know them all pretty well
Howard Johnson comes to mind because I
because of his death that's a short time
ago I got to know him because we had
student unrest here you know for a
period of time I wrote him a note saying
that on the basis of what I knew about
Berkeley it would be wise if he kept in
contact with the faculty during the
Pauli exclusion excitement that's going
on and he did better than that he had
two committees a faculty advisory group
and the student Weiser he who bag and
sag we called it at the time and we met
frequently and were made aware of what
the issues there were always a crisis
coming up all the time and so that was
something special and when it was over
with we had a party at our house for
Howard and since then we've become very
good friends that's one example of
something that happened Paul Gray I
don't think people realize how much Paul
and Priscilla dead for MIT in terms of
supporting the search for women to come
here make he had a more amenable place
for everybody and my case I got involved
in trying to get african-americans here
again through Paul's push in our chair
at the time Ken Hoffman so on several
occasions went on for example I think I
gave a talk at Georgia Tech and used the
occasion to visit a technical school for
african-americans in engineering school
and I went there and talked to the Dean
of science and the members of the
faculty it's very funny if you want a
story I given this talk at Georgia Tech
and I had this appointment but we played
tennis first afterward and so I ended up
at the campus with my tennis racket
luckily because those were difficult
moments between places between
african-americans and Caucasians and I
walked on the campus and the first look
of students was a glare at me but then
they saw my tennis racket and smiled
so that was my entree and I went to talk
to the math department a teen was there
he was very antagonistic because
he thought somehow MIT was trying to
take away some of his power and that was
unpleasant the discussion we had going
nowhere he was just protecting his power
he left and then the faculty relaxed and
we had a very nice chatting and they
were very pleased to have someone of my
stature come down and talk to them
another occasion with which did work
well was I went to Howard University and
I had talked to our chair at Kent
Hoffman who hurts me to go was that hard
trouble with getting african-americans
this they don't want their best students
to come to MIT they want to keep them
and I suggested that maybe we could have
them come during their junior year and
then go back for their senior year and
report on their experiences at MIT and
that would be constructive and so I went
and it worked out we had two women come
up I only kept track for a while with
one of them and she had a terrific
experience and later on became head of a
company or a leader in some
administrative capacity down in the
south I've lost track of it but sort of
was always knowing that Paul and
Priscilla were behind many of these
things and now we're just good friends
as a result of that checklist and I
became good friends as well because he
comes from Michigan and that's where I
went to the University and I see yeah
so I talked to talk to him a lot he
invited me to he asked me forgotten who
was going to be the new inauguration of
a new president the universe' Michigan
but he asked me to represent him I T at
that inauguration I was pleased to
through that nice to get back to home
base so to speak and I told you Jerry
weast there and I I've known him from
way back
I would always consult with him one and
he was always so positive and
constructive about everything did you
ever have an interest in in
administration no no not at all I've
been lucky to avoid it except for the
big chair of this committee in
Washington and I had a very good staff
who took care of everything
and of course I was on the search
committee for Susan Hawtree Oh No and we
had just what she came and talked to us
so I felt we were close friends
the moment she talked about what her
ideas were for MIT um have I left
anybody out and that period of time oh
you don't think so I don't think so yeah
who was president when you arrived said
Howard Johnson knows before that
someone I didn't know then okay let me
ask a little about the school of science
yeah I'm wondering if you have any
thoughts about what its strengths are or
its role at MIT your impressions of the
school itself well I own a couple of
teens they've been terrific marks are
terrific teen I don't really have any
comments because and I make a lot of
contact with physics department because
that's physics seminar they have a very
strong faculty and they're postdocs are
very good now they weren't for a while
but they are very good now and I've seen
some of the people grow and I really an
integral part faculty so those are the
only two departments I know I don't know
biology really know what makes a good
graduate student or a postdoc well for
me it's again the interface between
fields the eagerness to understand
what's going on between fields and I
have people that there who are in that
category now in physics how about the
strengths of the do of the mathematics
department well it came in first in the
popularity ratings this year and it did
five years ago
and I think rightly so and this means
not tied for first but first and that
shows that we've we're recognized for
its strength
one of the things that's happened in our
department is attention to the
undergraduates and preparing them for
these various competitions which they
more or less win or close to winning and
that created an understanding with high
school students that MIT was the place
to go and so we've been very lucky that
we get you know finalists and various
competitions Riceville coming to MIT
so the MIT undergraduate program right
now although I'm not part of it at all
they have to take into account that they
have brilliant kids coming in who are
ready for anything when they arrived and
are well advanced beyond anything that
we've really seen we may see it in one
or two students in the past but now it's
common for those under graduates and our
grad students who come they're just
excited about coming here because
there's so much going on so we've
benefited by that combination of
exciting undergrads grad students now
much better program of students we have
now than we had say 10 years ago my
criteria was where do they go after they
get their PhD where they end up didn't
look too good before now it's looking
much better since you have the
perspective of being here for a long
time can we talk a little bit about the
changes that you've seen tap out in the
culture has that changed and the time
that you've been here
we don't really know what culture means
in this context the one thing the only
thing I've noticed is that students have
much more say in what's happening at MIT
than they used to I think that's all for
the better and may also have a different
attitude when I first came to MIT
it was very strict they did what they
were told they better do it or else that
kind of tech as hell was was not there
but there were a reflections of it are
the relics of everything we're there and
now it's not it's not true at all
students have a lot to say what's going
on they have much more flexibility
that's that's part of the generosity I'm
talking about flexible to do what they
want
we've learned that student may come in
with an idea that they're gonna major
and field X and they end up and doing
something entirely different and have
different aims and interests by the time
the second year and having learned that
it's been built into the program so
we're much more flexible much more
generous and we used to be Europe for
Xavier up for example is something that
was not there a long time ago and that's
another example of generosity of taking
people how our kids really in spending
some time with them and I don't do that
but a lot of my colleagues do and I
think it's a very important program
that's a lot for the student and in fact
students have become so good and also
does a lot for the faculty member
especially in laboratories why do you
think it's so much better for students
to have a greater say in what's going on
at MIT I think they're pretty astute and
so when they see things that are wrong
they now can speak up about it
in a way that they hadn't before so for
example going back to when I talk they
have his TA students in my class would
invite me to some event lunch dinner or
something like that and they would talk
freely about the difference between MIT
and Harvard in a way that didn't happen
years ago so there is stood there
constructive so their insights are
important
how about changes that you've seen in
the faculty I don't see much difference
actually when I see that's different is
the climate then what's there in when I
don't see them any different I think
they are is focused on a combination of
research and and teaching as we were
earlier on
I don't see much difference the one real
big difference is we're certainly the
women in the math faculty are very
gung-ho about making sure that women are
well represented in the field and they
have lectures by women on mathematics
they're also probably more socially
oriented than we were years ago but in a
different way so changes they're simple
enough
we were very socially bound in the sense
that we would have a party after every
colloquium and wives would come to that
party and we got to know everybody quite
well now of course that's changed a
great deal because we're at work much
more independent they were and there are
no such parties they're too many
cloaking anyway so we couldn't keep that
up and so that's been separated and the
sociability occurs in different ways
that has the increase in women in your
department has it changed the department
in ways I think it has is there do you
in what ways can you speak to that at
all well well I spoke to any students
I'm sure that women's students feel much
more comfortable because they have women
they can come and talk to which was
difficult a long time ago I think
there's more sociability in the in the
department than there was before more
parties more celebrations more contacts
in the department as opposed to parties
at somebody's house as there were years
ago
have you seen MIT change academically
over the years in any significant way
greater in their connection between
fields bioattack for example us
something that's very important is
fairly new and I don't know much about I
think the interaction between
departments is increasing rapidly it's
one thing I tried to promote in this
seminar I have it does seem to be a
trend and Emily yes any institutional
turning points that you've seen or that
you want to speak to I wouldn't know
anything about that and as I told you I
don't find it
oh I'm out my pack
what things have we not talked about
that you think are important to say can
be anything about your own research
about MIT about your hopes for MIT in
the future I think we've covered
everything that I can imagine I just
like to say that I've been very
fortunate and the support I've gotten
from MIT and growing up here at MIT and
having the freedom and opportunity to do
the things I wanted mathematics and
fortunate that I feel confident that I
can continue doing it so what will you
be working on after June my tennis game
throw hot but I mentioned that I think
something can be said about black holes
that involve a new form of geometry
noncommutative geometry and there's some
connections between topology analysis
and geometry that haven't been pursued
by others and I think I can have
something interesting to say the main
thing is I can afford to gamble you know
why not
and I will gamble and I'll enjoy doing
that that's what you're supposed to do
when you retire
I say okay thank you so much thank you
a pleasure to talk to you
you